hola buenos días bueno pues hoy es una
fecha en la cual conmemoramos ese coraje
esa valentía de las personas refugiadas
y desplazadas en el mundo y también es
una oportunidad pues para hacer un
llamado a los líderes mundiales para que
trabajen en solucionar las causas del
desplazamiento los conflictos que
obligan a las personas a salir cuál es
la diferencia entre una persona
refugiada migrantes solicitantes de
asilo las personas refugiadas son
personas que no tienen otra opción más
que salir de sus países para sobrevivir
porque han sido víctimas de persecución
por su por su raza por su orientación
sexual por su orientación política y las
personas solicitantes de asilo que no
pueden volver a su país los países
tienen la obligación internacional de
acoger a estas personas ya que volver a
sus países supondría
un temor un riesgo para su vida las
personas solicitantes de asilo son
personas que han solicitado esa
protección internacional pero que de
momento están esperando a una resolución
por parte de los países de acogida bueno
pero si bien este es el día del
refugiado también la problemática se
vive todos los días en todos los países
y también deriva muchas veces en actos
de xenofobia o discriminación hacia los
refugiados de que vale la acnur está
promoviendo el respeto por estas
personas
es importante darse cuenta de que cuando
un país abre las puertas a un refugiado
lo que hace es salvarle la vida
que nadie quiere salir de su país que
salen de su país por obligación y con
muchas ganas de construir de recomenzar
su vida
desde acnur trabajamos muy de cerca con
las comunidades de acogida de estas
personas refugiadas del 82,4 millones de
personas que comentabas el 20 por ciento
están en américa latina en la región de
las américas y estas son las regiones
más solidarias del mundo con los
refugiados y con las personas
desplazadas pero obviamente es
importante que la comunidad
internacional apoye a las comunidades
que los sacó claro que en gran medida en
la mayoría de las ocasiones son personas
que también tienen muchas necesidades
por supuesto y como promover una
política migratoria internacional más
justa que le permita a las personas de
todos los países migrar en condiciones
seguras sin arriesgar su vida
recurriendo a caminos ilegales
rápidamente por favor
es importante buscar soluciones
alternativas como por ejemplo hemos
visto en colombia en febrero que se puso
en marcha un estatuto temporal de
protección lo mismo están haciendo otros
países también buscar soluciones para
facilitar la reunificación familiar y
sobre todo asegurarse que esas rutas que
se toman son seguras que se identifican
las necesidades de protección de las
personas que llegan a las fronteras para
evitar que se vean expuestos a los
riesgos de usar pasos irregulares